كان الهدف من الشراكة مع
أدوات نستله والسير أوليفر هو تطوير
وجبات غذائية شخصية كاملة
للطيارين للحفاظ عليها أثناء
تشغيل الدور الذي يدير التحدي العالمي
جيدًا ، فأنت تعلم جيدًا ما تعلمناه من
كل رحلة طيران أقدم والرقم هو
ذلك مع الأخذ في الاعتبار  أن الطيارين يقولون
وقتًا طويلاً في أماكن ضيقة جدًا
بدون الكثير من الحركات
ولديهم الكثير من الاحتياجات من حيث الطاقة
ولكن الشهية ليست جيدة جدًا وهذه
المعلمات كلها تفكر في
كبار السن كبار السن
وهذا هو 301 دافئ  ولكي تكون قادرًا
على تسخين هذا الطعام ، عليك
أن تضيفه في هذه الدائرة في كيس
ثم تضيف كمية قليلة من الماء
فيه ثم يؤدي ذلك إلى تفاعل كيميائي
مع تفاعل طارد للحرارة ولكن
ينتج عنه بخار الماء.